people of the internet retro wrecking
tour here and welcome back to
return in this video today we continue
to make progress through
eternal learning more about the game
getting a couple of upgrades and also
meeting what i think is our first boss
this dude's back this was also streamed
over on twitch and i'm still
really enjoying the game hope you guys
like these videos as well
if so give it a thumbs up and enjoy
all right i'm gonna explore this area a
little bit more
before we leave here so i think that
little triangle symbol thing
is the uh the translocator so i can
teleport somewhere else
in first person shooters like one of my
buddies in destiny he got me
using l1 to jump and it just like feels
so much better to me now
but i don't know how i feel about it for
third person okay so that warps me up
here
confirmed point-to-point teleportation
location exit seems fixed
yeah that one it took me directly here
it didn't give me a choice
now i don't think we can make that jump
going across there let's take a look at
our map again
okay so we're back up uh we're up here
now
so let's see where does this come out
i think in fights like when i'm actively
fighting something i feel like that
l1 will feel feel more natural
what is this up there
just because i'm so used to it from
first person shooters on console
okay yeah this is that's okay this is
definitely
that looks just like some of those
switches that we were
shooting earlier
no stay away
you heading out hey good talking to you
man now won't be streaming tomorrow
night
won't be streaming tomorrow night right
now i think thursdays and fridays
or wednesdays and thursdays are going to
be my streaming
hold x and r to use see like for that
x is not going to be great for using the
item
it's not going to be great because i
can't it won't really
allow me to do to do both
okay back in here oh my objectives right
there
but yeah have a good night dude have a
good night i'm gonna go ahead and switch
back
for now
let's just switch back to adaptive
yeah put jump back on that
just because i think for the item use if
i have to use the right stick
with l1 then with
x i can't do it
all right so now we can actually use
this awesome all right here we go let's
activate this
where is it taking us all the way back
up here
oh that purple one is an ether let's go
i think that's only our second one
though
large resin suit integrity increased
yes please we definitely need that
all right our primary objective though
top right corner is still to locate
the white shadow broadcast
all right i didn't i didn't do this one
yet
see where this one takes me if i've been
to this place before
uh oh
i don't think we have
i don't think we have area scan yeah we
did this earlier to reveal
exits
oh wait wait wait
oh i don't think i can make it dude
i really wanna i'm curious to see if i
can get up there but
i'm afraid to try it clearly this seems
like the direction we're supposed to go
whoa look at this place man
discovered xenotype technology that
produces other devices
this looks like a little upgrade area or
something yeah i knew it man
i knew it obelet repository a device
that exchanges ether and oblites for one
another
it seems poised to do something if
enough oblates are placed in it
cooperation with other scouts
is encouraged exchanged 300 oblets and i
get
five i believe that's five ether
fabricator wait come back come back
why is it not telling me what they are
a xenotech device that fabricates items
powered with oblets dude
i don't know enough about the items yet
i'm kind of afraid
what's this over here integrity augment
increases max
integrity by twenty five percent
it costs three twenty five i only have
three twenty nine
or three i have three forty nine
let's see if is that the same thing over
here
no insufficient ether
wait do i really have 99999
i really need one more
no i have 349 obelisks what the heck
oh dude lots of currencies we got to
figure this out all right i'm just going
to interact with this i want to see what
happens here
okay so that allows me to look at these
four things so we have a recharging
overload
successful overloads reduce all fire
cooldowns
by three seconds now here's what i need
to know does this
does this stuff carry over or not to my
next runs
surely it does because otherwise like
what would be the point of spending
anything
gain plus five percent weapon damage per
adrenal level
that could be super helpful right there
for sure grants a
huge amount of weapon proficiency
and then this one is a large silphium
vial it's consumable nah
definitely not spending that much on a
consumable suit artifact recharging
overload
suit artifact okay let's back out here
now why is this like in a separate spot
because to me like this seems by far the
most obvious one to do
if this increases my maximum integrity
by 25 percent
that seems like a no-brainer to me and
this i can exchange 300
wait now it's 97.99
it does say com cooperation with other
scouts so i guess like other people are
using it
all right i'm gonna do this one right
here i'm gonna do it man
hopefully this sticks with me i mean i
have to think it will
that wouldn't make any sense if it
doesn't and like
even after you die that should
definitely stick with you
fabricator pod oh look at that and it
gives us
it restored some of our health too
didn't take it all the way to max though
okay so this has been depleted can't do
it again
and now i shouldn't make sure i was
looking at the right currency
yeah i don't have enough for this
so that was obelitz yeah so now i can't
do
i can't get uh ether from this
i don't know though man like i think
that was that was worth it
i always strive to go for that
in games to to increase my health if
possible
all right so now let's see where else
can we explore here
so like next time like if we die it's
not going to look like this anymore
is it really it's really not gonna like
i won't be able to go to that same
upgrade spot anymore
there's definitely an enemy over there
dude it's crazy how it
homes in on like where you should be
shooting
like what is it trying to hit over here
or are they just
bouncing everywhere all right did i get
rid of all those statues
i think we did unknown object
potentially beneficial potentially
potentially beneficial guys trophy
unlocked
currently lacking resources to decipher
this xenoglyph
insufficient xenoglyph ciphers
writings by the sentients find and
collect xenoxenoglyph
ciphers to translate them okay
this almost looks like a lever or
something that i'm supposed to knock
down
like shoot out the vines or something
maybe
now this looks like that's supposed to
be a door eventually
an eye looks like a closed eye right
there
see those little red lights back there
all right there's one of those things
something more for me to scan over here
another potentially beneficial
discovered a fragment of the xenotype
language hey that's the xenoglyph cipher
right there
so wait now can i go back to this thing
i should be able to right
stop the endless cycle okay so if i get
another cipher
theoretically it would translate a
little bit more of that
right okay yeah so it still just shows
me
now i can go one of two ways here i can
take this little portal
the translocator
destination selectable
very interesting
now is that the only spot i can go right
now that's probably the only
like
yeah so it's just where i'm at right now
and then this one right here okay i
don't i do not want to use that
i want to press on this way
what is going on here
setting a marker on my map
can i resistance of projectile damage
and i bet i can't
dash through it either nope okay
find a way to destroy xenotech barriers
what if i charge
nope nope just deflected
let's see okay the optional spot is on
our left
oh yeah
whoa these dudes are huge
adrenaline reset because i got hit right
there
oh my goodness oh my goodness
wait something where did he come from
i'm dead i'm almost dead dude
i'm about to die
no no
there's more in there oh it's the same
one
no dive something get out of the way
yikes i lost so much health right there
even after just upgrading my health man
those things were nasty
they were nasty i see some health up
here though
dude are you serious
i wonder if i'm you think i'm actually
supposed to let the vines pick me up
how crazy would that be how crazy would
that be if you're supposed to let them
pick you up to get like and then you
sort of jump off
ah this timed it
dude you can dash pretty far further
than i thought at first
no no
i was so close to getting help man
well oh my goodness dude this is not
what i wanted to do all right this this
may not be too bad though
like it creates a pretty wide gap right
there if i
jump dash grab whatever whatever that
blue thing is
and then jump dash again i think i'll be
okay
there we go nicely done
all right where are you taking me one
way yeah get me out of here
get me out of here please
okay wait am i back in that room now i
am i'm back in that room
where we were just at
okay that's that's the side area i
definitely want to go in there
but first
i wonder if there's a point to
destroying the statues
or if it's just like for destructive
just showing off their effects you know
oh i see i see some health
yes okay that's big time dude
that's big time we needed that
those vines are creepy
okay how did we get up there last time
we were close to being able to
yeah this way
like yeah i don't think i don't think
that jumping dash would work if i had a
double jump
oh you are supposed to get caught in
them
that's what i was wondering man because
yeah you can dash out remember that
that was like one of the first things
they told us early in the game is how
you can dash out
of the vines oh there's another statue
up there
i hit it too early again all right now
if i drop down here
okay just kind of a little oh wait i
just saw more
health when i see some blue up top there
can i really not destroy this with with
that
that's that's amazing to me and there's
no way to get in that way
all right so i guess we need some other
type of weapon
and it still didn't say anything about
how to
oh that blue that i saw was just the
light right there okay
i still haven't read anything about how
i can
get my pistol back out
i don't like the statues i don't like
them
uh destination selectable
oh see now we've got three destinations
unlocked that's awesome
all right don't really want to use it
right now though okay we know you can't
go
in the water guys we figured that out
very early on do not
go in the water
what the heck is the point of this area
then
what is the point of this area
okay find a way to destroy xenotech
barriers that's
that's my focus right now that's what i
need to be working on
so let's take this back actually no why
would we take this
because i mean it's telling me my
objective is down there i think i just
need to continue on
the path right up here yeah and take
take a left up here
stay away from the vines
i just i don't like the statues
i'm getting rid of them
oh this is another weapon let's go dude
let's go a spit mall
blaster okay so look at that
it is a slug shot horizontal
barrage and then bonus damage and it's
also rated level one
whereas this one that i have is level
zero right now so blast shell
is what i currently have this one's
gonna give me a horizontal barrage so
we're definitely gonna swap
and of course we're immediately going to
get attacked by something
oh this kind of like shotgun style man
yikes
you run out a lot faster this one has
way less ammo
and this thing does crazy damage
dude he's so close to death
come on there we go
got him
oh my goodness lock down lifted
like that the uh all fire is pretty
powerful but i don't know if i just like
i don't know if i like the slugs
like that because you only get what how
many was that six
one two three four five six
and we hit the overload right there
okay so maybe this destroys the xenotech
barriers though
okay so if i go immediately behind me
that way
what's back here
what is this oh you're gonna like
throw this on your suit too
dude this lady seems docile
what is wrong
oh my gosh oh look beside her did you
guys see that
somehow it's strengthening
and weakening my suit dude no wonder
she's in trouble man
like is that her right there parasites
have both beneficial and detrimental
effects to your suit
press to access your status to learn
more about attached
parasites okay i want to look at the
tutorial first
oh we missed this one about augments
augments increase
their associated stat when picked up
they are automatically applied to the
relevant stat
and do not show up in your inventory
augments are often found
in special fabricator pods sometimes
even for no
cost interesting
sometimes even for no cost that's crazy
i had to pay a bunch for that
for the health upgrade all right here's
the one on parasites parasites are
strange fauna that infest
atrophos and affect your suit in
different ways while some might alter
the way your suit is repaired
others can prevent death entirely okay
that's pretty cool each parasite has
unique buffs and debuffs
some parasites automatically detach
after the buff
is depleted but most stay on until they
are forcibly detached
via a device or a consumable
okay let's read that last part again
some are automatically detached after
the buff is depleted most stay on until
they are forcefully
interesting so how do i know what
the buffs of this parasite are
oh that's creepy man that's creepy
i don't know what's going on dude i
don't know what's going on
i need more health again though surprise
surprise
oh and there's another door right there
that we haven't taken yet
let's see if there's any other doors
that we haven't taken mainly that
like this door right here kind of gonna
zoom in on a little bit for you
and then this door right here we'll go
that one first i mean since it's right
outside i mean this has got to be the
way to destroy the xenotech barriers
right
this this weapon
one would think
oh it's one of those things
let's see here
destination selectable if i use this one
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go right here i'm
gonna travel back to that one and then
because i missed that i missed that spot
that we were
probably supposed to go
i need to take a left and then just kind
of go straight
so we're gonna go through here oh this
area
yeah yeah no no
no no not this area what
where'd i mess up supposed to go through
here
yeah yeah right through here
oh this one okay here we go let's test
this out man
nope
okay so that upgraded weapon does
nothing to this right here
that does not destroy the xenotech
barriers
all right so now we need to go back yeah
right over here
and then we need to go back to
uh
this one t4
target location
oh dude the statues are back
i don't like the statues get the statues
out of my game
get them out
yikes i'm dead
oh i didn't hit him at all with that man
oh there's another one
oh no this this okay this is a lesser
enemy i still could totally die to it
though trust me
oh is that health yes please
no no i'm so close to the health
yes full health let's go
nah i don't want the full on not for
this guy
i'll save it for the big one down there
or is that the big guy
there we go there we go
enhanced overload wait he could upgrade
my weapon
overheat limit
man this thing is so cheese this thing
is super powerful but
i still don't know how i like it
see what the range well not going to see
the range right there
because that's just gonna take him out
like can i hit this dude from here not
really
oh yeah i mean it's let's switch it out
though
oh yeah there we go there we go
enhanced vision oh we got another one
right there behind us
didn't mean to do that did not mean to
do that get away from the tentacles
away from the tentacles
oh come on
i i do not want to pick that up right
now wait what did it say though
feels one slot toward max integrity oh
cause that's the resin thing
kind of like a zelda heart piece
where'd he go dude
do i have time for a quick scan on this
creature
hostiles leave behind a pool of acid
upon death
you know what why not we're in the
experimental phase
we're in the experimental phase dude
oh and there's the pool of acid so will
that affect me i wonder
yes it does yes it does
if you were wondering does the asset
affect you
the answer is yes so what's the point of
it then maybe it also i hope it hurts
the enemies
otherwise why did i just do that
why did i just take that okay so this is
a side area let's go in this one first
whoa
ah too early
whoa okay that one's a powerful statue
right there man
fascinating xenoarchive
technology that records historical
events
okay okay
anything else gonna happen here nothing
narrow maul look at that see that one
the one i have right now i think i like
the track or swarm better though
i do although the narrow maul
let's see let's see like what the
difference is if it's a much tighter
spread
it is but
i'm gonna stick with this one for now i
think i just think for where i'm at in
the game
dude look at the effects on this this is
crazy
okay the red is for the weapon upgrade
i need to know if there's a point for me
destroying all the statues
fabricators i really need to know
yep we have used those
all right anything else to interact with
needs five ether malfunction probability
very high i made it all this way
now you're telling me i need five ether
malignant silphium repairs moderate
damage to integrity but it is affected
with
malignancy cleanse with two ether
interesting i don't think i would want
to do that though
would i want to waste my two ether
i'm just gonna pick it up and take on
the suit malfunction
while in midair 50 weapon damage okay
that's actually not too bad
and i just need to collect two resin to
make it go away
weird yeah this room is crazy right here
what is that thing xeno just tell me
that's the xeno archive
this feels like a future power-up
something that i don't have yet
oh goodness almost just fell off
yeah i don't know if i'm supposed to do
anything else in this room here
i still my primary objective i still
need to find a way to destroy
xenotech barriers and it's way down
there like it's down
low i need to get
oh this was just a side air anyway
that's right that's right i can keep
going
and keep going to the right over here
right over here
that's where we gonna go
oh dude that one's
it's a powerful attack rather
same enemy but that was a powerful
attack he just unleashed
yikes didn't mean to fall down here
don't like it don't like it let me out
let me out all right is this the only
thing we can do in here
no there's another side area and then we
can drop
all the way down all right we don't
really need to use that
right now
what is this thing i wish you could scan
this like metroid prime
i really do
yikes
no come on get back up
red door right here though oh we do have
a key
repairs augment increased repair
efficiency and doesn't cost anything
i mean sure why not
does it remove that thing is that what
happens
fabrication materials depleted
oh just tell me i can't use that thing
anymore okay gotcha
what is that thing oh fabricator all
right
like i mean
should i try and land on the green
it's health right
that's weird
put health on on the thing where
take major damage it probably i'm sure
there's something you could probably
unlock later on
all right yeah let's drop down now dude
let's drop down
you're supposed to go over here to do it
yeah here we go
i still need to get two resin
actually no not over here
i'm scared oh we can just drop right
here
where would you take me ah short
distance travel the question is
where malignant
abelite chunk contains large amount of
oblets
but it is infected with malignancy
xenotech required malfunction
probability high needs for ether to
cleanse
i don't think i'm supposed to i mean if
i use that let's just see where is it
gonna
yeah it just takes me right back up okay
so this one will take me down so i don't
have to
we don't have to do that little jumping
maneuver that we did
first time are you serious man
where the heck am i
obelet chunk a damaged xenotech device
fabricates a random item in exchange for
an increasing
uh random item nah
nah i'm not playing that game i don't
think so
not right now not while i'm still trying
to learn and figure this out
okay perfect puts me right back here no
oh i forgot about
that stupid acid man
hey ether okay let's go that's three
ether that we picked up
seems like e3 is hard to find but very
valuable like you need that for a lot of
things
anything around here
okay let's press on oh is that a
house
excuse me that's
that can't be here oh what
oh my goodness oh it's look at that
actually labeled on the mouse on the
mouse
it's getting late guys it's getting late
labeled on the map as house
what in the world
surprise surprise we need health again
okay let's scan this scout log
i think i am reliving my
parts are memories others seem
manufactured
but i can't remember the torment feeling
like i was losing my mind
there's no comfort here no safe space
and the astronaut keeps following me
what
the astronaut keeps following you
what are you talking about
what are you talking about
locked
can we open it
nope can't lock can't open it
but to me that implies like later
we might be able to open that you think
okay yep i heard that i definitely heard
that
show yourself oh there's a bunch of them
whoa
oh look at him dude
nice
yeah up that adrenaline level
is that it
dude this game is so cool oh he still
had that thing disables all turrets
within the area
seems like it might be useful oh let me
out of there
oh another weapon upgrade blast shell
armor piercing
i gotta try it dude
i gotta try it man
oh is this am i on the pistol now oh no
it's not okay
i still need to find two resin
to get rid of that malfunction that we
got going on there
good now we can scan this broken
calibrator
small silphium
all right let's take a look at the map
here oh why is this one red
we're still trying to find a way to
destroy xenotech barriers
that's still our main objective right
now
i had a little question mark up here
another portal
destination selectable all right we've
unlocked six of these so far
so that's good we've got we're getting
closer and closer man though look look
how close
i feel like the next maybe two rooms
should put us in that in that spot
uh oh it's not good though area in
lockdown
all upcoming weapons improved
that's what i like to hear man that's
what i like to hear
this dude's back
all right i will say this area is a lot
larger
giving us more room to maneuver
did we get him we got him
let's go lock down
lifted tracker swarm for the pistol but
it's level three
modified sidearm
i don't know man this one that i was
using this tachyomatic
tachomatic carbine
was pretty strong on that guy
yeah i think i'm gonna bonus damage
overload projectiles and fire rate
yeah i just i think i'm gonna can i
it is automatic
i'm gonna go back to this one though
this one did really well against that
little mini boss right there
really well
okay let's see oh okay we got a lot
going on we got two optional areas
and then we've got our objective let's
hit the let's hit the optional areas
and then maybe we will finally get to go
and check out our
ultimate objective there now this is an
interesting place
yep i knew i knew
it wasn't gonna be that easy
i knew something was gonna jump out at
us
oh it's the light dude it's the light
and you shoot them and they close their
eyes
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
all right what are you here unknown
device all right let's scan it
again another potentially beneficial
rest yes
can be used to recover and increase
integrity looks like it
already did but i'm going to go ahead
and do it again
i'm gonna make sure we are full on
everything that we can get
nice all right let's do this
let's go we can finally get to our next
destination here
i hope i hope behind this wall
oh wait no oh wait first we gotta see
what's over here
then we can go over there and see our
objective that we've been looking at for
so long
yeah that makes them close their eyes
oh that's my dog oh but i can't no no no
i didn't mean to do that
adrenaline reset of course i don't think
i can get in here yet because it's red
oh i do i have a key i still have one
key
large silphium
man i don't know if i want to do
feels one slot towards max integrity
upgrade
yeah i think i'm gonna take that chance
lose obelisks okay while in midair 50
lose omelets when suffering damage
collect parasites all right
and then this stuff will will go away
but i still need to collect i've got one
resin i need one more resin
okay let's look at the map real quick
yeah the device over there we already
know about that okay here's where we
want to go
oh not what i'm meant to do
now what i meant to do all right this is
the main room
i still need to go over here
and then then after after we check out
this one
oh dude for a side area this is a huge
area to explore
all right let's scan this one
house key an antique key for a 20th
century house
my house key of course we're gonna pick
that up dude
how could this be here
okay if you didn't already know lady
like
something something really strange is
going on here okay
oh i still only have one cipher
do i go back to the house
no no no we gotta we gotta go check out
this area first man
i feel like it's been building up to
this for a while we gotta see what's
here
we gotta see what's behind this door
over here
our main objective will we finally find
a way
to destroy xenotech barriers
i know one thing another television
construction oh boy
oh xenotech required
oh maybe this guy gives us the xenotech
required
let's see man she seems to be totally
open to all these aliens just like
latching and granting her powers but
also
sucking the life out of her at the same
time
oh this could be the device we need
whoa
yo that is not what i was expecting
that is not what i was expecting
press square to perform a melee attack
why am i so pumped about performing
melee dude
that's why right there because we can
get through those vines now can break
obstacles that are resistant to
projectile damage such as vines and
energy barriers
some hostiles can also generate shields
which make them immune to long-range
attacks when encountering a shielded
hostile
you can eliminate it easily with a melee
attack
dude the gameplay in this
as you get further and further
i just know is gonna be absolutely
bonkers man
requires crimson key
use the blade to destroy the xenotech
barriers
there you go that is how you destroy the
xenotech barriers you have to unlock the
melee
oh dude that's so awesome that's so
awesome
all right so now we can take that uh we
need to take the fast
travel let's see what would be the
closest one
probably this one right up here to our
right
i want to test it on these guys too can
we zone statue
yes we can yes we can
let's go
all right uh no i need to go back
through there and then i need to get up
top
it's the wrong way
yeah go this way go up the stairs
and then it should be back over here
yeah and then we'll have the little
portal
it's got a little bit of a cool down on
it but again it's not it's not crazy
all right let's use this and dude
i mean i'm kind of like should we go
back to the house
because we also have that key let's do
this one first
because i definitely think we're gonna
be back at the house at some point too
otherwise why would you have the key you
know
all right get my bearings again
get my bearings here
okay we need to take an immediate left
and go through the next door as well oh
there it is right there that's it
use our melee to destroy it
yo look at how big that is man
it's like groot
destination selectable again we got a
bunch of these things now
seven in total all right
all right you gonna attack me statue
probably so right when i scan this
probably so
opens the anathema vault
get out of here dude
oh here we go these little bats
come on come on
is that all you got
then just like a massive one imagine if
a massive one just comes out from
or the statue itself finally comes alive
where the rest of yet anymore back there
any more of them back there
dude there's got to be a point to
destroying the statues right
right
discover the anathema's keys purpose
all right man you know what i think that
is a fantastic
spot for us to stop and end the stream
um
guys this has been awesome man we went
over two hours here that's kind of what
i was planning on
it's a little after 2 a.m my time but
first impressions on return on man
this is gonna be incredible like i want
the gameplay to pick up a bit
it's been more exploratory than i would
like early on but definitely getting
some metroid vibes which i love
i can see the signs though that once
once the shooting
really picks up once the gameplay really
starts to get going
it's going to be insane dude it's going
to be absolutely insane we'll probably
be streaming this next week as well
if you're checking this out on youtube
thank you so much for watching make sure
to leave a thumbs up
and as always guys thank you all so much
for watching
i'll talk to you again soon